sie habe das video sicherlich auch
gesehen der tritt gegen den polizisten
der polizist blieb zum glück körperlich
unversehrt aber wie wirkt sich so etwas
auf die psyche eines solchen menschen
aus es ist sicherlich schwierig solche
situationen zu verarbeiten erstmal bin
ich auch sehr glücklich dass den
betroffenen beamten nichts passiert ist
man muss sagen dass die psychischen
reaktionen oft erst zeitversetzt
aufdreht es kann in folge von gewalt
erlebnissen zu depressionen kommen ganz
suchterkrankungen kommt kann zwar
angsterkrankungen kommen oder im
extremfall auch zu posttraumatischen
belastungsstörung
wie häufig sind solche
belastungsstörungen
also sie können davon ausgehen gerade
beim erleben körperlicher gewalt ist es
so dass es bei etwa 10 bis 15 prozent
der betroffenen dann tatsächlich zu
einer posttraumatischen
belastungsstörung kommt und wir sind
dann die therapie möglichkeiten wenn zum
beispiel ein beamter hat zu ihnen kommt
also zuallererst gibt es erstmals um
stabilisierungen darum zu vermitteln
dass er in einem sicheren umfeld ist
überhaupt wieder vertrauen aufzubauen
bei betroffenen geht auch das vertrauen
in mitmenschen verloren sie verlieren
das vertrauen in die gesellschaft
verlieren das vertrauen sich überhaupt
wieder sicher bewegen zu können
oft ist es dann ein langwieriger prozess
wieder zu behandeln wir behandeln häufig
mit behandlungszeiten auch zwischen
sechs wochen
und es ist eine intensive
psychotherapeutische unterstützung
notwendig um die folgen der gewalt
wieder zu behandeln und letzte frage
vielleicht noch was können politik und
gesellschaft tun um die beamten zu
schützen
sicherlich was der herr von der
feuerwehr gewerkschaft gesagt hat ist
richtig es geht auch um ausrüstung aber
aus meiner sicht geht es häufig auch um
gewaltprävention wenn man sich die
tätergruppen anguckt sind es in der
mehrzahl junge männer die auch mobilität
über soziale medien suchen die häufig
alkoholisiert sind die häufig ohne
beschäftigung sind und nach sinn suchen
also ich denke nicht nur ausgezogen ist
eine maßnahme sondern auch beweis
prävention in der form dass bestimmte
teile der gesellschaften nicht verloren
werden das auch zu diesen bauteilen
kontakt besteht und auch bereit
präventive maßnahmen eingeleitet